we were one of the earliest SAS
companies Bas cam was launched in 2004
we didn't even have the SAS term back
then running your own software was a
total pain in the ass so everyone was so
excited when SAS comes out oh I just
have to fill in a form and I can use a
piece of software amazing and we jumped
on that and have been running base camp
and a ton of other services hey.com our
new email service SAS businesses 20 plus
years but one of the things I love is
this idea of the pendulum swinging right
we go from client to server back to
client back to server many times over
the uh history of computing we've gone
from one extreme to the other I think
it's time for that pendulum to swing at
least a little bit back towards you
being able to buy a software product
rather than buying a software service